it's time for seen and unseen when we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that we turn to Fox News contributor
Raymond Royo Raymond the president just
declared a new foreign policy Doctrine
wow well he declared something Laura
Scott P did the rest there's limited
fighting already on the Northern Israeli
border and I wonder what is your message
to Hezbollah and its backer Iran
don't don't don't don't
don't come across the border don't
escalate this war that's
right Laura we went from make America
great again to don't nice of Scott py to
fill in the blanks and read Biden's mind
there he could have said don't come out
after dark don't turn the call to prayer
up too loud and Biden would have said
that's right that's right right well
where went from Hope and change to don't
Ray um don't is that it's kind of the
perfect motto though for Biden we think
don't we don't have a thriving economy
we don't have a leader who can actually
speak and we certainly don't have the
Border that's secure of our own yeah
well and and he also might say don't
walk up steps without tripping I mean
this was the other day in Pennsylvania
and he stumbled along it's turning very
sad Laura the president spoke at a Human
Rights Campaign event over the weekend
and it was like he'd never seen an
audience before he was kind of sh
shocked when he got in front of the
crowd then once he did speak the
president inverted the yelling part with
a whispery part we got to stand up and
holler we got to stand up and holler
we're the United States of America and
there's nothing beyond our capacity when
we do it together nothing nothing
nothing so let's stand together and get
everyone else on the
deal
oh that it is something else Lord he's
he is fading faster than Tim Scott's
presidential Ambitions it's just
dissolving right before his eyes I saw
Tim took those U campaign ads down
that's kind of out the window all right
Ray now see if you can make sense of of
this the president in the middle of this
speech to this gay rights group started
talking about
guns who in God's name needs a weapon
with 100 rounds in a
chamber the weapons only meant for one
thing to kill
people I don't know about 100 rounds in
a chamber Laura but there are blanks in
his chamber uh there's a bit of happy
news to report though I want to bring
you something uplifting the White House
is taking your advice you know the
difficulties Biden has had exiting the
stage he never knows where to go he
never knows where the exit is exactly
well they've deployed a seeing eye lady
to escort him in the right direction it
was beautiful to see
[Music]
[Applause]
I Laura I guess with the dog gone she
now Pats Biden on the head and kind of
directs him and moves him to where he's
to take his walk this is she went from
first lady to First Sherpa I guess
she'll show up at the end of every
speech now well Raymond I I said that
they need to get all that tape and those
decals that they use there he goes again
falling on the on the grocery store
floor remember you could only walk one
way in the grocery store during Co those
old liberal women would scream at you if
you went the wrong way like screaming at
me in the grocery store but like they
need those little decals for him but I
guess those didn't work I think they
tried those so they had to yeah deploy
deploy for a no yeah he didn't see them
so he needed her you know and and and I
guess the big policy message of don't
I love that don't is not a sentence
don't is the beginning of a sentence
don't what Mr President but I guess when
you got Scott phy around he can fill in
the blanks and Jill tells him where to
go so somebody's always there to help
but I'm sure that they would If This
Were Trump they they would have a very
helpful media helping him out to answer
questions right they would just they
would constantly be nudging him forward
if that were although Trump's not
allowed to speak anym apparently um
Raymond before we go our friend Suzanne
Summers such sad news of course
everybody of a certain era and that's me
um actress singer entrepreneur she
passed away over the weekend she battled
breast cancer we had that in common but
she was such a wonderful um wonderful
friend uh joyous person we had her on
the show a few years ago and we asked
her about possible a possible thre
company reboot watch this I have an idea
oh I have an idea mean the three of us
give it away
here she was so such a great lady Lauren
a good friend she was married to her
husband Alan Hamill for 46 years Allan
was devoted to her throughout the cancer
treatments and their long marriage which
we discussed as
well what's the secret to a 40-year
marriage my husband and I have this
great partnership we compliment each
other a lot in mean it and gratitude I
wake up honestly every morning and I
talk about how grateful I am for the
life that I have and him and love and
family and all that oh
condolences to Alan and the whole family
uh just amazing person a bright light
and we wish her family um Peace and
prayers for them and may Suzanne rest in
peace Raymond thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else